hi i'm pete hammond and welcome to uh
scene at the academy
uh where we get to analyze uh one or two
scenes here from a movie that you have
seen
that are on the academy uh screening
room
um and today it's greyhound a terrific
film here
we're going to be talking about that
film with four of the key players here
first off it's star
and screenwriter here tom hanks hi tom
guilty and uh another academy award
winner a
fine director get low you may have seen
that not guilty
and speaking of speaking of
cinematographers uh
multi honored by the asc with many of
his uh
projects television movies uh so many
different things and that's shelley
johnson
i i think i was acquitted
[Laughter]
and then uh two-time oscar nominated
costume designer for
frida and 12 monkeys and that is julie
vice
hi julie well hello i plead temporary
insanity but uh it's
great to be part of this company and boy
i'll tell you
we have seen so many different movies
you
made a few of them yourself tom you know
but this is a
war that keeps delivering to hollywood
as it were
there are many stories and this is one
that's really never been told
well i would say it's because um it's
not a genre piece per se
that um any any movie worth itself from
any that is
written from about any period of time
isn't going to work if it only
celebrates the nostalgia
for the moment this is about human
beings standing on a bridge
for the better part of 36 hours dealing
with one damn thing after another
yes there is very specific procedure
that is there
naval procedure you know convoy
procedure what have you
but what there really is is an
inclusivity for the audience
to ponder how did human beings get
through that and the bigger question i
think that is what i always
look for in in a movie just when i'm
sitting down at home watching
it is what would i do if i was in that
circumstance
how would i get by that in that
circumstance then the wow factor which
is wow
i didn't know that um is
is demonstrated even in this first
sequence that we're talking about
in which there is danger out there a
submarine that we never
see in fact we don't see anything uh
kraus doesn't see anything
the crew doesn't see anything the
audience doesn't see anything
and yet there that danger lurks and i
think primally
we all we all react to that circumstance
we all react to that danger
because we've had that kind of like
spider since tingling in a circumstance
where danger is about we're not sure
where it is
sir he's going hard left
right standard
right standard runner aye sir
all right stay sharp rapid maneuvers
let's plot it
contact indefinite reports contact
indefinite no propeller noise
no contact sir
yard sir
600 yards sir mr lopez stand by with a
medium pattern then i'm ready sir
contact being port zero zero reports
contact airport zero
zero one range five hundred yards sir
contact barrier one
sir
hydrophone's strong very strong
hydrophone struck very strong sir
overlapping screws there he's trying to
slip over
aaron so you guys chose this particular
scene
opening scene it's worthy of hitchcock i
gotta tell you you know
in terms of uh the way the suspense is
built here
uh just like tom says the unseen uh here
so can you talk about it take us through
uh this particular scene and we'll talk
to uh each of you about from your
point of view of it it's a it's a good
example of
the overall challenge to a movie uh from
the point of view of a destroyer
captain and as tom mentioned the unseen
enemy
you essentially have a game of cat and
mouse going on
but unlike a classic cat and mouse game
as a director i can't see the mouse all
i have is
an empty ocean surface this mouse is
scurrying to the left
and krause chases it then it scurries to
the right and he re-steers and the
audience needs to understand that and so
one of the things that tom and i did to
help convey that
was inserted into kraus's body language
as krause is getting those rudder
commands
and being made aware that it's moved
here and then here
his body language is shifting back and
forth so
we used kraus himself as a sort of a
visual indicator of what was going on
and this this such is the challenge when
you're making a movie
about you know competition robbers but
you can't
you can't cut to the robbers out the
front windshield of the of the cop car
right
and then of course tom's performance is
the conduit for all of this tension
it's the focal point tom's staring out
those portals that nothing but equipment
and white screen so it was a big job for
all of us
to take in a virtual world and a world
that nobody really understands because
they haven't seen this kind of thing
before and make it accessible for an
audience
as soon as i saw those round portholes
when i went to visit uh
either the case in young that is up in
boston or it was the kid itself that is
in uh baton rouge
i was flabbergasted that it it
essentially the size of a washer dryer
you know it's like
the bridge kind of looks like a
laundromat there's like these these
small
round windows and that's the only
purview
that he has of what is out there unless
he goes outside
so even the smallness of what you what
light comes in and what you do gets
you do get to see belies the fact that
there is
there is this very very malevolent
creature that is out there
and so the um you match that up
with from from an actor's point of view
which is
this is the very first time
krause has come across this in in
reality
theory gone training gone that's ancient
history
what this is the first sub that he has
come across
and he can't see it that sub is going to
either sink him or wreak havoc
with uh with his protected flock and he
can't see it
he knows it's out there he can hear it
sort of he could get the
reports of kind of like well it's over
there oh no it's not it's over there
it's going this fast now it's going a
little bit slower and just
just that alone gets allows me as an
actor to play
a type of mixture of fear
anxiety blended in with a small degree
of confidence
but more than anything else i think
there is that
very very human and recognizable emotion
of not wanting to [ __ ] this up pardon my
language
not wanting to make the mistake that is
going to lead
to death destruction and his own
humiliation
that's an awful lot to put into one
thing but that's what
that's what was in the screenplay as as
adapted
and one of the things i admired about
the screenplay
the writer per se is not is counting on
the actor
to uh convey the focal point emotionally
of the scene
and the first thing that came to my mind
when i read it was
that scene in close encounters where the
airport
traffic controller is speaking with a
captain over the radio about
seeing a a ufo you don't cut to the
captain
you don't cut to a ufo it's all centered
on this radio control
operator the room the language i think
that's for me anyway what makes
it so thrilling and terrifying is that
you can just even though you don't
understand it you know you're in an
environment
that feels absolutely authentic and
you're almost digging
for the for the drama and tension
underneath it you feel it more than
the scene is speaking it you know as an
actor i i look at that and i realize
there's only five people that have lines
in that scene
yeah and most of the lines are
repetitions of the lines that have just
been said
and so we have actors there's a sonar
man a hellsman the talker
me and um uh the officer of the deck
whose name i can't quite remember right
now but uh forgive me
but um those have to be really good
faces i mean
oh you know i'm a i'm a i'm a selfish
competitive actor i love
i love having big freaking close-ups i
like that but without those other faces
or without those other guys
saying delivering their lines with the
import and the impact
and the same sort of confidence and
procedure and training
um that anybody would have that that um
you you don't have the cracker jack
scene that's there and
the other requirement is that shelly has
to shoot the living daylights out of it
in a way that is going to make all those
pieces fit together
so many scenes from the back from the
front with the windshield in when the
windshield
out close but you know where you can see
the the beeping sonar screen and what
have you
man there's an awful lot of elements
that that when in that four
dialogue wise is a bunch of repetitions
of the same line
uh without all those without all those
things coming in
um you don't have the building blocks
for something that is as
hyperkinetic as it is that's amazing
shelley talk about that
yeah and that particular challenge and
most of this is handheld
it is it the the entire movie's handheld
and um
the it's interesting because as they're
saying when you're reading the script
you know as a cinematographer you're
looking at your scene and you and you're
you know you're you're trying to figure
out what parts the narrative you can
bring out visually
you know well in this script because
because of the procedural nature of the
dialogue
so much of us left to interpretation and
my own interpretation and conversations
with aaron and i
kind of hope expanded an even wider
interpretation of it and and
uh uh but when you finally see the
actors
do it on the set with each other well
that's when it
you really start to understand what the
what the scene is about and
and um not really about the dialogue at
all but about the situation and so a lot
of what we were
trying to pursue was uh this has
happened early in the film
was actually giving the audience a
position as though they're standing in
the pilot house and
and eavesdropping so some of these
angles where we have where we're kind of
you know almost three-quarter behind tom
eavesdropping on him but seeing his eyes
and seeing
him strategize i mean one of the things
that strikes me about this scene there's
so many
strategic moves you're thinking about
where you can put the camera to put that
audience
right there next to krauss and that was
fun it's amazing and julie
you get to see your costumes for the
first time there and uh talk a little
bit about that and
and what went into doing basically what
is
what some people would call a uniform
kind of movie assignment here for a
costume designer
well the word uniform
is um in a theosaurus it would probably
say
uniform something that
is specific and
i do believe that i believe that in a
uniform it defines
there's a dignity in it there is a
position
and for tom hanks
becoming kraus there is
a level and a definition and
watching that happen that uniform is
extremely important it is something that
needs to be followed and
the fitting watching tom
become crafts that is
part of why certainly i am a costume
designer
to see an actor merged
knowing when to stop that's very hard
uh let's talk about the final scene
which
um is so emotional for the audience but
you don't
you don't try to get that it's just
there it's just so natural and so much
of it
played on your face tom well it's the
moment where he's relieved of his
command
without so much as well he gets a little
bit of job well done to it but at the
end it's like
procedure takes over okay we're here now
okay so you're
you're done um so what do you do well i
guess he's going to try to go
go downstairs and try to go to bed
mr carling she's all yours
i will be in my cabin if you need me hi
yes sir
[Applause]
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the first scene that aaron
talked about um
when we first met about uh him directing
and it the the i think the worst the uh
a director's worst nightmare is having
to meet with an actor
who has written his own material that's
that's just like fraught with there's
one pitfall after another that's going
to go along
there but um the first thing that he
the the very first scene that he
mentioned was um
when krause is relieved of this command
and to hear that from the director who
say he's all
he's already talking about my interior
process
he's always he's already talking about
the ultimate
the ultimate moment of an arc for me as
an actor
when it's all done and i've got nothing
left nothing left to do
everything up to that point has led to a
moment of what
all right i guess i'll go back down and
if you need me i'll be in uh i'll be in
my quarters
um i i look i get i get knocked out by
that kind of stuff because i can sort of
like hear the french horns
but i did not take into account um what
what aaron saw to it is in
which is the the pondering of of
everybody on board
on board that that bridge uh
that is matched with now the uselessness
of the commanding officer and then he
also saw to it that we added these other
moments
of uh krauss coming down hearing the
cheering coming out realizing that
greyhound as uh as a as an escort and a
protector
and therefore krause's its commander is
getting a massive i could get
i can well up just talk about it right
now is getting is getting a
thank you so very much for what you just
did with him
when when you just get to see it and you
don't have to talk about it
when no one says hey they really like
the job we did skipper where it's
just plays off in the visuals and in the
eyes
that that goes beyond uh writing on
on a page it ends up being just pure
cinema
and when you that's the best kind of
movie you could have
is when you you see it without any
explanation you know exactly what
is going through the heart and the mind
and the soul of uh
of the characters all in all brought in
it ended up being this kind of moment
that
took me by surprise when i saw when i
saw it at the end i thought okay it'll
be a nice goodbye
there there krause is and he's still got
his he's still got his dress blues on
from the
funeral he still looks like a million
bucks it all ends up playing in a way
that is
not uh it's not necessarily visual
but it certainly is ephemeral and that
ends up being very powerful
yeah well i have to say it's fascinating
to hear
these scenes as they're created and
congratulations to all of you
uh and joining us here on scene at the
academy for dissecting that
and uh and telling us more about this
terrific film uh
thank you so much thanks thank you
everybody
good to see you shelly good to see you
julie good to see you thank you
thank you thank you come on see you man